a trucker's life is tough says polish
driver piotr rasik
he's crisscrossed the continent for six
years
polish hauliers are the driving force of
european supply chains working long
lonely hours away from their families
i have uncles who've driven for 25 years
a big brother who's been driving for
more than 15 years and now my younger
sister has got a driving licence and
drives in the netherlands and she's
already had enough
the critical shortage of drivers many
from eastern europe has left the
continent in crisis with the uk hardest
hit
covert 19 put a stop to new driver
training and post-brexit immigration
rules designed to put british workers
first have backfired
british government plans to issue
temporary three-month visas for 5 000
foreign truckers have been scoffed at by
european drivers unwilling to help the
uk out of a crisis seemingly of its own
making
[Applause]
this is not an attractive proposition
for our drivers beyond the issue of pay
the job needs to be stable and secure if
a driver has an employment contract in
poland with a permanent employer why
would they quit everything and go to the
uk for two or three months just to help
the british sort out their christmas
and this is the ongoing consequence of a
shortage of around a hundred thousand
drivers some pedro pumps have simply run
dry elsewhere there are long queues of
irate drivers and there are now concerns
about essential supplies reaching
pharmacies in a week in which scuffles
have broken out at some petrol stations
the government insists the situation is
improving
but it's not just lorry drivers that are
in short supply
another crisis looms caused by a
shortage of butchers many from eastern
europe
the farming industries warned that
hundreds of thousands of pigs may have
to be culled within weeks unless the
government issues visas to allow more
butchers into the country
this is an interconnected crisis where
the worst effects of brexit and kovid
have collided spreading chaos in
everything from food to fuel
neave barker al jazeera london